[Applaudissements]
alors je voudrais que tout le monde
chante avec moi parce que le premier qui
chante pas il va payer la tournée
générale en sortant
ouvrez ouvrez la cage aux oiseau c'est
pas assez fort reg regardez les
sansvoler ses
mot les enfants si vous voyez les petits
oiseaux prisonniers
ouvrez-leur la porte vers la
[Musique]
liberté un petit d à coudre et trois
gouttes d'eau
dedans au-dessus du perchoir un os de
sèche tout blanc et un petit piaf triste
le vivre en prison ça met du soleil dans
la
maison c'est ce que vous diront quelques
rentiers
viscelard des vieux chnocs qui n des
trous d'Er dans le
cigare une fois dans votre vie vous
quiêes pas comme eux faites un truc qui
vous rendra heureux et avec moi
ouvrez ouvrez la cage au
oui un peu plus fort regardez les col
et les enfants si vousz les petits
oiseaux Pr
ouvrez-leur la porte vers la
liberté si votre concierge fait cui cui
sur son
balcon avec ses perruches importé du
Japon ses Canaris jaunes et ses
bingal à votre tour faites leur guili
guili sournoisement exclamez-vous Dieu
quel plumage mes chères madamees on vous
demande au trisème étage et des
clignolle or RAL dos
tourn même si on doit pas vous le
pardonner
[Musique]
ouvrez ouvrez la cage aux
[Applaudissements]
oiseaux regardez les sansvoler c'est
beau les enfant si vous voyez les petits
oiseaux prisonniers
ouvrez-leur la porte vers la liberté
ouvrez ouvrez la cage aux
[Applaudissements]
oiseaux regardez les sangoler c'est
beau les
enfants les petits oisaux prisonniers
ouvrez-leur la porte te vers la liberté
ouvrez ouvrez la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
CAN